-
♪ ♪
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
CBS AND 60 MINUTES COMING UNDER
MAJOR FIRE.
IT'S OVER A STORY THEY DID ON
THE GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS.
THE PROGRAM CLAIMED THAT HE GAVE
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT TO THE
PUBLIC IN THE VACCINE ROLLOUT
BECAUSE THEY DONATED TO HIS
CAMPAIGN, BUT THE FLORIDA
GOVERNOR HITTING BACK HARD
AGAINST THE ACCUSATION.
HE IS ACCUSING 60 MINUTES OF
DECEPTIVELY EDITING THE PIECE.
HERE'S WHAT THE CLIP LOOKED LIKE
WHEN IT AIRED ON CBS.
>> NOTING THAT YOU DONATED
$100,000 TO YOUR CAMPAIGN AND
THEN HE REWARDED THEM WITH THE
EXCLUSIVE RIGHTS TO DISTRIBUTE
THE VACCINATION.
>> WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS WRONG.
THAT IS THE SAFE NARRATIVE AND
THAT WAS THE COUNTY MAYOR, THE
ADMINISTRATOR AND ALL OF THE
FOLKS AT PALM BEACH COUNTY AND
SAID, HERE ARE SOME OF THE
OPTIONS.
WE CAN DO MORE DRIVE THROUGH, WE
GIVE MORE TO HOSPITALS, AND THEY
SAID WE THINK THAT WILL BE THE
EASIEST THING FOR OUR RESIDENTS.
>> MELISSA McKINLEY IN THE
EVERGLADES TOLD US THE GOVERNOR
NEVER MET WITH HER WITH THE
PUBLIC DEAL.
>> EIGHT WILL GO AWAY, GOVERNOR.
>> IT'S A FAKE NARRATIVE.
IT JUST GETTING USED TO THE
NARRATIVE AND YOU DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE FACTS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY I MADE IT OUT FOR YOU
IN A WAY THAT IS IRREFUTABLE.
>> AND HERE IS WHAT CBS CAME OUT
INCLUDING RON DeSANTIS
DECIDING TO CHOOSE PUBLIC.
>> WE WANTED TO EXPAND THE
DISTRIBUTION POINTS, SO YOU HAVE
THE COUNTY, SOME DRIVE-THROUGH
SITES COMING UP HOSPITALS THAT
WERE DOING A LOT, AND WENT TO
GIVING COMMUNITIES MORE SO WE
REACHED OUT TO OTHER RETAIL
PHARMACIES, WALMART, OBVIOUSLY
CVS AND WALGREENS FINISH THAT
MISSION AND WE WILL FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET DONE WITH THAT.
FOR THE PUBLIC THEY WERE NOT
READY TO GO, AND YOU KNOW WHAT,
WE DID IT ON A TRIAL BASIS, I
ACTUALLY SHOWED UP THAT WEEKEND
AND TALK TO SENIORS ACROSS THE
PUBLIC HOW IS THE EXPERIENCE?
IT WAS GOOD, IT WAS 100%
POSITIVE.
>> Juan: CBS CONTINUES TO
STAND BEHIND THEIR STORY SAYING
THAT OUR STORY SUNDAY NIGHT
SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
DANA PERINO, LET ME BEGIN WITH
YOU.
RON DeSANTIS CLAIMS HE IS
BEING SMEARED BY LEFT-WING
CORPORATE MEDIA.
HE POINTS OUT THAT CBS HAS NOT
DONE A STORY ON EMBATTLED
NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO.
BUT THE CBS PEOPLE SAY THAT HE
TURNED DOWN TWO INTERVIEWS.
SO I'M THINKING IS THIS A NORMAL
PRESS VERSUS POLITICIAN CONFLICT
THAT IS BEING BLOWN UP BY THE
GRIEVANCE MEDIA AND POLITICAL
POLARIZATION?
>> Dana: SOMETIMES I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU, IN THIS CASE,
NO.
WHEN THEY SAY THAT IT SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF, IT SURE DOES AND IT HAS
BEEN GOING FOR TWO DAYS.
IF THEY WANTED TO HELP
RON DeSANTIS SOLIDIFY HIS
POSITION AS ONE OF THE TOP
LEADERS IN AMERICA, THEY COULD
NOT HAVE DONE A BETTER JOB.
THE WAY THAT THEY EDITED THE
VIDEO WOULD'VE BEEN PULLED OFF
THE AIR IF IT WAS A POLITICAL
ADD IN THE OPPONENT COMPLAINED
IT WOULD'VE BEEN PULLED OFF OR
LESS.
I HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY
WITH DEALING WITH CBS ON SUCH
DECEPTION AND I DON'T THINK THAT
IT IS TOO FAR TO SAY THAT THIS
IS REMINISCENT OF THINGS IN THE
PAST WHERE THEY FORGED DOCUMENTS
AND ERROR TO THEM.
AND WHEN IT CAME TO
GEORGE W. BUSH'S NATIONAL GUARD
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN,
WEIGHT, REPORTS AND MOVE ON.
TO THE OTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS RIGHT NOW IS
TO MOVE BEYOND JUST TALKING TO
THE REPUBLICAN BASE.
HE HAS A GREAT STORY TO TELL
ABOUT FLORIDA AND HOW FLORIDA
HAS DONE IN COVID.
WE HAVE DAN BONGINO ON HERE WHO
CAN TALK ABOUT IT WITH MORE
DIRECT EXPERIENCE, BUT YOU'LL
FLORIDA AND TEXAS WHO HAD A
DIFFERENT APPROACH FOR DEALING
WITH THE COVID AND THE LOCKDOWN
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
KEEP THE ECONOMY OPEN WHILE
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE.
AND YOU HAVE THESE DEMOCRATIC
STARS OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
CUOMO WITH THE WORST RECORD.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
BEYOND JUST TALKING ABOUT CBS
AND EDITING THAT PIECE ABOUT
HIM, THE LAST THING I WOULD
POINT OUT IS THAT I INTERVIEWED
THE MAYOR OF PALM BEACH THIS
MORNING AND HE IS A DEMOCRAT WHO
RAISED HIS HAND IMMEDIATELY
AFTER SAYING THAT "60 MINUTES"
INTERVIEW AND SAID, THIS IS NOT
RIGHT OR WHAT HAPPEN, THIS IS
WRONG.
AND HE SAID THAT HE TALKED TO
THEM FOR OVER 50 MINUTES BUT
THAT NOTHING HE SAID WAS
INCLUDED IN THE PIECE.
WHEN THEY ISSUED ANOTHER
STATEMENT ABOUT THIS, THEY SAID,
WELL, WE TALKED TO THAT MAYOR.
YOU TALK TO HIM, BUT NOTHING
SUNK IN ENDING FEELS IT WAS
DECEPTIVE.
WHEN YOU HAVE A DEMOCRATIC
MIRROR DEFENDING THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR AT THE TOP OF HIS
POLITICAL FIELD, THEN YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE A PROBLEM AT CBS.
>> Juan: HERE IS THE VIDEO.
>> I PARTICIPATED IN SPEAKING
WITH THE PRODUCER OF HER
60 MINUTES FOR OVER 45 MINUTES
AND GAVE DIRECT IDEAS OF THE
GOVERNMENT MEETING THAT I HAD
HERE IN MY OFFICE A FEW MONTHS
AGO, AND WHEN I WATCHED THE
PIECE I WAS TAKEN ABACK REALLY
THAT NONE OF MY COMMENTS, NONE
OF MY PERSPECTIVE WAS INCLUDED.
>> Juan: KATY, TWO FLORIDA
DEMOCRATS INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR
SAW SAYING THEY AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR THAT IMPACT THEY
THOUGHT PUBLIC SHOULD BE USED TO
VACCINATE PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, 60 MINUTES
ACTUALLY NOTED THAT PUBLIC, THE
PUBLIC FORTUNE GAVE MAJOR
DONATION TO PUBLIC TO HIS
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE JUST
BEFORE THAT BIG CONTRACT WAS
GIVEN TO THE PUBLIC.
SO I JUST WANT TO FIGURE OUT IF
YOU THINK ISN'T THAT A STORY?
>> Katie: NO, FIRST OF ALL
$100,000 IN FLORIDA AS A
CAMPAIGN DONATION IS REALLY NOT
A LOT OF MONEY.
PUBLIC IS THE MOST POPULAR
GROCERY STORE CHAIN AND THEY
EXPLAINED THAT THERE IS A PUBLIX
WITHIN THE MILE AND A HALF OF
MOST SENIOR COMMUNITY IS IN
FLORIDA WHICH IS WHY THEY
DECIDED TO GO WITH A FIRST WHY
THEY DECIDED TO VACCINATE
SENIORS FIRST.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR PAY TO
PLAY WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY WHAT CBS
IS TRYING TO GO FOR, GAVIN
NEWSOM RECEIVED $23 MILLION FROM
BLUE SHIELD IN CALIFORNIA.
AND GAVE THE EXCLUSIVE RIGHTS TO
WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
SO $23 MILLION VERSUS $100,000
OF ROUTINE POLITICAL DONATION TO
RON DeSANTIS.
THERE IS NO STORY THERE ANY AT
AT -- CBS SAYS THAT THEY REACH
OUT TO THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
BUT WHAT I LIKE FOR THE STORY IS
THAT YOU LOOK AT FLORIDA AND IT
IS OBVIOUS THAT DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS UNLIKE THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY WERE ABLE TO RISE
ABOVE POLITICS AND PARTISANSHIP
TO GET THE JOB DONE WHEN IT CAME
TO GETTING PEOPLE VACCINATED
QUICKLY.
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THE FOCUS IS HERE AND WE
WILL SEE WHAT CBS DOES.
>> Juan: GREG, YOU HAVE
POLITICIANS, AND MINORITY AREAS
IN FLORIDA POINTING OUT THAT
THEY WERE NOT GETTING ACCESS TO
THE VACCINE IN A COMPARABLE WAY
TO PEOPLE WHO WERE WEALTHY
LANDOWNERS TO RON DeSANTIS.
IS THAT FAIR TO POINT OUT AS A
CRITICISM?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW, BECAUSE
IT IS SIMPLY ONE VARIABLE.
WHEN YOU ARE DOING SOMETHING
LIKE THIS, THEY ARE A NUMBER OF
VARIABLES GOING ON IN TERMS OF
AGE AND RISK FACTORS.
THE THING THAT GETS ME, THERE
ARE TWO THINGS ON THIS.
AND WHEN 60 MINUTES IN THEIR
DEFENSE HAD THIS BRAG THAT
STIRRED DEBATE AND PROMPTED A
STRONG REACTION.
BUT THE NEGLECTED STATE OF THE
DEBATE THROUGH ITS CORRUPT
METHODS, AND CREATING THIS
DEBATE.
SO INSTEAD OF SAYING MY
INCOMPETENCE RAISES AWARENESS OF
INCOMPETENT PEOPLE, THE STRONG
REACTION IS OVER THE DISHONEST
MANIPULATION OF TAPE IN THIS.
AND CBS CLAIMS THAT THEY EDITED
THE PIECE FOR CLARITY, THAT'S
LIKE SAYING WE ARE LYING FOR THE
TRUTH, BECAUSE YOU CAN CONSIDER
THIS LOGIC THAT THE CONTEXT GETS
IN THE WAY OF A STORY.
AND SADLY THEY KIND OF OUR
RIGHT.
THE GRIM INTENTION ALL ALONG IS
TO SHAPE THEIR NARRATIVE.
AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT YOU HAVE
TO REMOVE THE CONTEXT WHETHER IT
IS WATCHING THE POST OF THE
COVINGTON KIDS OR KATIE COURIC
WITH THOSE GUN OWNERS OR
60 MINUTES, THEY LOOK AT
PEOPLE'S LIVES LIKE A BLOCK OF
CLAY AND IT IS UP TO THEM TO
CARVE THE STORY OF DISCORD OUT
OF IT TO MAKE MONEY, BECAUSE THE
POSITIVE UPLIFTING STORY OF
WHICH THERE ARE MANY, THAT'S NOT
GOING TO GET THEM CLICKS.
THEY HAVE TO FIND THE NEGATIVE
ELEMENTS IN EVERY STORY.
AND IN THIS CASE WAS LINKING THE
PUBLIC TO THIS.
BUT THIS IS ALWAYS THE MEDIA'S
GOAL, POSITIVE STORIES DON'T
HELP.
THE GOAL IS TO MANAGE
DESTRUCTION OF YOUR TARGET.
IT IS THE RICHARD JEWELL EFFECT.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW A LOT ABOUT
FLORIDA AS DANA WAS SAYING, IT
SEEMS LIKE RON DeSANTIS
FORTUNE POLITICALLY ARE RISING
AND DEFENDING HIM, HE IS A HERO.
BUT WHAT YOU GET IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAYING, THIS IS THE SAME
GUY WHO BELIEVED THE CLAIMS OF
ELECTION FRAUD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THAT WAS INTERESTING HOW YOU
THREW THAT IN THERE, JUAN,
REALLY NICE TRY.
THIS IS A TOTAL LIE, A STORY
DESIGNED TO APPEAL THE IDIOTS.
SO IF YOU ARE A, THE STORY ON
"60 MINUTES" ABSOLUTELY APPEALED
TO YOU.
DO YOU THINK THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING THERE.
IT'S TOTALLY MADE UP AND NOT A
SHRED OF TRUTH TO IT.
IF YOU ACTUALLY LIVE IN FLORIDA
LIKE I DO, YOU CAN'T SWING A
WIFFLE BAT WITHOUT HITTING A
PUBLIC, BECAUSE THERE IS ONE IN
EVERY DIRECTION.
ALSO PUBLIX DONATES TO EVERYONE
IN FLORIDA BECAUSE THEY HAVE 816
STORES IN FLORIDA, SO JUST LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE THEY DONATE TO
POLITICIANS.
LET ME BRING SOMETHING UP.
IF YOU WERE GOING TO DISTRIBUTE
THE VACCINE, WOULD YOU DO IT IN
A PLACE THAT HAD --
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE FOR
LIBERALS, SO THINK THIS THROUGH.
TAKE THE BLINDERS OFF AND THINK
THIS THROUGH.
IT DO YOU WANT TO PUT IN A
LOCATION THAT IS 800 OR 300?
I KNOW THAT LIBERALS, THEY HAVE
BEEN VACCINATED TO THE TRUTHS,
RIGHT?
I KNOW THAT THAT'S HARD FOR THEM
TO FIGURE OUT, BUT 816 LOCATIONS